next time I introduce you probably
little eye contact and next time don't
refer to me as your son the half-baked
writer
you shouldn't need my approval to write
everyone needs approval job I'd like my
wife to get on the extension hello I'm
on tell me this isn't some great big fat
joke it's a real diamond Oh
welcome to Stockholm we're so delighted
to have you here that came across some
of your stores in the college Journal
beautifully written Joe had a very heavy
hand as a teacher he encouraged you to
keep writing a writer writes because he
has something personal to say you write
with intelligence but you're detached
the characters are supposed to be
detached especially the mother my wife
doesn't write thank God
otherwise I'd suffer permanent writer's
block don't ever think that you can get
their approval
who's the men the ones who decide who
gets to be taken seriously
a writer has to write write has to be
read honey
I am aware of Joe's various
indiscretions his affairs have nothing
to do with you that's a deep-seated fear
of inadequacy
don't paint me as a victim I am much
more interesting than that
now walk away from me damn it I can't do
it anymore I can't take it I can't take
the humiliation
what are we doing John were not bad
people I think you are sick and tired of
Joe Castle I would like to convey to you
the warm congratulations of the Swedish
Academy we have reinvented the very
nature of story tell me about yourself
we have an occupation writing and what
is that
[Music]
I am a kingmaker
you